Elon announced this was two days ago
that the new CEO of Twitter is going to
be a woman named Linda yaccarino now she
is a former wef World economic economic
Forum affiliate formerly of NBC she's in
ad sales
but some video is leaking out of her and
people are going to have to try to make
some sense of this I would just preface
this video by saying I'm willing to give
Elon the benefit of the doubt here right
like
he clearly knew that this is what her
history was they've obviously had some
discussions about it they've already
agreed to do a live Twitter spaces where
people can ask her whatever they want
but it is an alarm it is an alarm and
it's worth noting so here is the new CEO
of Twitter this is her back in 2020
talking social justice and equality
we can talk about you know things that
that my company is doing to
accelerate right to accelerate what we
were doing already but realizing that it
wasn't enough so what immediately
started happening was that under the
leadership of Brian Roberts and Jeff
show uh Comcast set up a fund to the
value of a hundred million dollars to
fight social justice and equality and
and obviously supporting many many
important groups but it really made a
very public statement that
we're going to put our money where our
mouth is we're not going anywhere and it
inspired action across every corner of
our company
okay so I'm pinning this just as a as
kind of a note to Elon Musk it's like
all right if you're hiring her as a CEO
here she is talking about how the
company she used to work for through 100
million bucks towards social justice and
the organizations around that now that
seems to be to me to be counter to all
of the things you've been talking about
so he's going to have to have a
reckoning related to that again he did
say he's going to do a Twitter spaces
this is sort of their live audio back
and forth where people will be able to
ask her questions he still remains in
charge of the the product itself so it
sounds like she's going to mostly be
doing the sales side of things but look
when when the walksters get into any
organization we've seen this time and
time again they basically destroy every
organization so Elon I would say is has
a very very tight rope to walk right now
to make sure that this thing doesn't
totally derail we shall see
foreign
[Music]